GPS satellites are constantly bathing the
world in their electromagnetic signally glow,
but how EXACTLY do these satellites find you?
Saying a satellite finds YOU is very Enemy
of the State, very NBC TV government drama;
but GPS satellites don't actually track you,
they're simply broadcasting a signal that
you pick up. What would be a more accurate
way to look at it is, GPS doesn't find you,
but you find it.
The Global Positioning System is network of
around 30 satellites, a receiver, and a SUPER
accurate clock; all pulled together with math.
The system was created in the 1980s for the
military, but they opened it up for civilian
use, and it has since changed how we find
directions, look for pizza, and connect with
each other. But how it works, requires a TON
of incredible science.
Firstly, we have to know what time it is.
I know that seems strange, but if you don't
have a SUPER ACCURATE measure of time, you
can't do GPS!
The most accurate measure of time humans have,
is the constant, predictable vibration of
an atom. The U.S. Naval Observatory in Washington,
D.C., is the official United States time.
They mark time, by measuring billionths of
a second using 9,192,631,770 electron vibrations
of a Cesium-133 atom. This atomic clock is
accurate to nanoseconds… which is super
important.
Secondly we have to have a satellite network
which ALSO know the time. As of October 19,
2015, there were GPS 31 satellites with three
atomic clocks on board, as well as transmitters
to send microwave signals out at the planet
below. The system is flying at 11,000 kilometers
per hour, about 20000 kilometers above our
heads (7000mph/12500mi) and is maintained
by the U.S. Air Force. Those signals?
Those are what are telling you where you are
on the planet!
Okay, so. GPS signals are sent at exact intervals.
Say…
every few seconds. Embedded in microwave signal
is the ID of the satellite, the health of
the satellite, the location of all the satellites
in the system, and the precise date and time.
VERY precise. Because Tens of thousands of
kilometers away on the ground, the signals
will be picked up by your smartphone once
you click, let the pizza app know your location.
Smartphones and GPS units have to have very
precise time, because microwave signals travel
at the speed of light, roughly 300,000 kilometers
per second, so in a fraction of a second,
the signal travels from each satellite to
you!
This is why we need atomic clocks, because
20-30 nanoseconds matter!
But we'll come back to this in a sec. The
receiver can tell where each satellite is,
by the difference in time lag. Using a mathematical
process called trilateration the GPS unit
can determine your exact location. Basically,
a sphere is drawn indicating the time lag
from each satellite and the overlapping point
is your current location!
After ALL THAT, the pizza app knows exactly
where you are.
Before you get confused, there's NOT an atomic
clock in your smartphone, but as long as the
smartphone clock is pretty good, it can will
regular updates from the Observatory clock
and stay on track!
The more satellites it can "see" the more
accurate the location. If you pick up three
satellites, your GPS can determine your 2D
location (latitude and longitude), but with
four it can tell your altitude too!
As you move, the time lag from the satellite
to the antenna of each signal will change,
and by constantly updating the trilateration
math, the location dot on your map moves.
Even after all this work just to get a pizza
delivered, there's a ton more complications.
Satellites need replacement, and only have
an operational life of 7-15 years. So they
have to keep launching new ones. We're on
our fifth generation now, and they're getting
a lot better, but they're not perfect. The
satellite signals can bounce off an ionized
layer of the atmosphere called ionosphere
-- AM radio bounces off it from the ground
too. It's not friendly to signals going through
it. But on top of THAT GPS satellites are
traveling FAST and far away, meaning Einstein's
General & Special Relativity comes into play.
Even if the atomic clocks are super accurate,
the ones on the satellites are ticking faster
than the Naval Observatory clock, because
gravity is stronger on Earth and they're moving
so fast!
SO!
The GPS has to mathematically calculate and
adjust for the roughly 45,000 nanoseconds
per day of difference in time; since being
off by 20-30 nanoseconds can make the system
pretty much worthless. This a big deal. It's
frickin' crazy.
Thanks to the space program, Einstein's relativistic
physics, atomic clocks, and smart phones,
you my friend, can get a pizza delivered to
your exact location -- give or take a few
feet. What do you want?
We're not perfect. Yet. The next generation
should get us within inches.
And thank you also to the US Air Force for
sponsoring this message, and making sure the
pizza guy knows where to come. Every day American
Airmen go above and beyond to break barriers
both professionally and personally. The United
States Air Force is powered by Airmen, fueled
by innovation.
Crazily enough, your BRAIN has GPS too, after
a fashion. A set of cells creates a map of
the stuff around you…
No, no, I'll let this super handsome guy with
a great t-shirt collection explain it.